tonight is the season finale of how to
get away with murder
and one thing we know for sure a Shonda
Rimes show always goes out with a bang
here's the big question what surprises
could we be in store for tonight
backstabbers will be revealed just tell
me someone's got more blood on their
hands and the body counts about two
o'clock okay so we know a couple things
from the promo first thing we know
there's at least two more dead bodies
right you know Shonda has taught you
well so quickly that's Billy Brown who
plays a cop and viola Davis's secret
lover talking only with our nischelle
Turner about his steamy affair with the
manipulative law professor are you at
any point saying you know I'm done with
the sex scenes I just no no no you never
say and the super rip stars being super
tight-lipped about whether they'll still
be together and fill more sexy scenes
what do you do to prepare the pomp mints
do you do push-ups to your like flex
what do you do before you take it off
nothing yeah just sure that's all you
got to do so viola was just talking
recently about um getting injured on set
and she mentioned in particular one of
the sex scenes you know we go through a
certain amount of pain mm-hmm so our
passion our work maybe that's what
propelled her to get that in it you know
I mean maybe that was the thing that
pushed her over the top like that any
votes